Right?
So this is just B,
two,
five one and this morning I want simply
to introduce the class and to explain,
uh,
what it might offer to you.
Um,
first of all,
it's obviously an outline course.
It deals with a large period of history,
uh,
200,
250 years covering what I described
in the title as early modern England.
Um,
well that's a label that may or
may not mean very much to you.
Uh,
I could have called the course tutor and
Stuart England and indeed that term is
used in the subtitle.
It is about England in the reigns of
the tutor and Stuart monarchs running
roughly from the 1480s to the 1710s.
Um,
but to call it that might suggest that
the course is structured around the
rulers and that like so much history,
the focus is very much on the top.
Well,
in part it certainly is.
Um,
in introducing the political narrative,
which will form part of
the core of the course,
I'll certainly be looking at the lives
and the times of the great figures who
gave their names to the age
and the faces on the coins,
you might say.
Um,
the notorious Henry the eighth and his,
uh,
six unfortunate wives,
um,
who are always difficult to
remember in the right order.
And Lucy,
you have a,
a helpful phrase for this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Divorced,
divorced,
beheaded,
died,
divorced,
beheaded,
survived the lucky one.
Um,
Henry the eighth,
um,
the stunning and a rather perplexing
Queen Elizabeth the first Gloriana good
queen best the Virgin Queen.
Whether you imagine her as a
Cate Blanchett or is Judi Dench,
uh,
she,
she still has the glamour,
uh,
a woman who announced to
her people earlier in her
reign that she would not make
windows into men's souls.
She would not make
And she's continued to resist the
efforts of most historians to try to make
windows into hers.
And then there's the four Stuart kings,
James the first described at the time
as the wisest fool in Christendom.
A man who after an adventurous
youth as king of Scotland,
became King of England,
and it was said,
treated every day thereafter
as if it were Christmas Day.
Um,
Charles,
the first his son whose
policies precipitated civil
war in the mid 17th century
and who was eventually put on trial
and executed by his own people in 1649,
um,
his son Charles the second restored to
the throne after 10 years of Republican
government,
Charles known as the Merrie monarch,
a man who was energetic
principally in his pleasures.
I'm famous for having innumerable
mistresses and a 14 illegitimate children.
Uh,
never don't know.
No legitimate children at all.
I'm never happier than when swanning
around St James's park with one of his
mistresses and Hispaniola,
um,
the,
you know,
the King Charles Spaniel,
nice little black and white
spaniel named after him of course.
Um,
and,
uh,
the king looked rather like a King
Charles Spaniel when he had his wig on.
The nice curly is as it were.
And,
uh,
and uh,
he had nice Brown eyes too.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
his brother James the second former Duke
of York came to the throne and after
three years was driven from it in the
second English revolution of the 17th
century,
driven into exile later known as the
king over the water by those who remained
loyal to him.
Well,
it's been said that two of the Stuart
kings were politically astute but morally
defective and to a virtuous men whose
political ineptitude cost them the throne.
To Paraphrase Oscar Wilde,
we could say this remarkable dynasty
that to lose the throne once could be
considered a misfortune,
but to lose it twice,
suggest a certain amount
of political ineptitude.
Well,
you will hear and read about all of these
people and the many others who shaped
England's public destiny and
political destiny in this period.
Uh,
and others too.
And today's September the third,
which reminds me of a Oliver Cromwell,
he was born and died
on September the third,
and also fought his two greatest
battles on September the third,
which is probably no coincidence.
It was his lucky day.
The Great Puritan General,
the Lord Protector of
the English Republic.
Between 1653 and 1658 a man described
as a man of agonies and exaltations.
They're quite extraordinary figure and
idealist in some ways ahead of his time
on religious toleration,
for example,
in other ways tainted by the bigotry of
his age and historically perhaps more
loved and more hated than almost
any other figure in British history.
So there are other great ones,
but there's also a much more to it,
uh,
than can be approached by
focusing on such figures alone.
And if about a third of the lecture
course is devoted to the political
narratives and the,
and understanding how they unfolded,
the rest is devoted to other aspects
of the period to its religious history,
to its social history,
aspects of its economy,
aspects of the culture of the time.
Uh,
these are matters which might sometimes
have been vitally influenced by the
decisions of rulers,
but they also developed in their own
independent ways and they obviously
involved a far larger cast of characters.
So this course is very much about the
common people to and their experience of
the age as well as about
those who ruled them.
So like one of the Great Hollywood epics,
we have a cast of millions.
That's why I'm using the more capacious,
if Vega label early modern England,
by which I mean simply the broad period
between the end of the 15th and the
middle of the 18th century,
which saw the laying down of what were
to become the essential characteristics
of modern Britain in government,
in religion,
in economy and social structure,
in culture,
in political values.
So I'm inviting you then to take a journey
of the imagination through two and a
half centuries.
But you might say that was
an awfully long time ago.
This is the kind of
history that's long dead,
that's drowned in time.
Why should you concern yourselves with
the distant past so remote from your own
contemporary experience?
Why bother with England or Britain?
Why does it matter?
Well,
I'd say there are at least three good
reasons for exploring deep history
and
in a way that takes us way beyond the
immediacy of a more familiar historical
world.
First of all,
because to do so is
imaginatively enriching.
Uh,
it involves rediscovering the lost
world and that takes imagination.
Secondly,
because it's also
intellectually demanding.
All history of course involves us in a
fairly rigorous intellectual discipline.
We have to develop
arguments about causation,
about why things happened
the way they did.
And we do that by establishing a dialogue
between the questions that we want to
ask and the evidence which
the past has left to us.
Well,
my point is simply that that can be
a peculiarly and throwing exercise,
four periods of the distant past for
which the evidence is often ambiguous or
difficult or partial,
um,
in which it's produced by unfamiliar
institutions in which people are thinking
with unfamiliar casts of mind.
And we have to try to think ourselves
into those minds to understand what was
happening in their own terms,
informing our causal arguments that
can stretch you imaginatively and
intellectually.
And thirdly,
and perhaps most importantly
because it creates meaning.
It helps us to understand ourselves in
time in a deeper way by exposing 21st
century attitudes and values and
experiences to a much deeper comparative
context.
Looking at the distant
past can alert us to the,
to the sheer otherness of the past,
to the reality of deep and fundamental
change in the course of four or five
centuries and to the provisional and
contingent and temporary nature of so much
that we take for granted today,
as well as the family resemblances,
which can still be found.
That's an exercise which can be
enormously provocative and stimulating a
challenge that helps us understand
better our own place in time.
Right.
Well,
the story of early modern England has
got a good deal to offer in all of these
respects.
It can certainly capture the imagination.
This was a time of great events.
The reformation,
the civil wars of the 17th century,
the foundations of the
first British empire.
It was a time of great personalities,
the rulers that I've already mentioned,
but also it was the age
of Shakespeare of Milton.
The time of the diarist Samuel Peeps,
the Protel Democrat,
John Lilburn,
the early feminist writer,
Mary astral and so on,
could go on.
It was a time of great
processes as well as events,
longer term processes,
great changes in the
structures of society,
in economic development,
in political culture,
in the growth of literacy
and print culture.
And it's also the period when almost
for the first time in British history,
we have the evidence surviving
that enables us to get
to grips with the mass of
the population and to explore the
everyday dynamics of their lives,
their relationships,
their emotional palettes.
You might say it's only from about the
early 16th century that the sources
survive in large quantities that enabled
imaginative historians to approach the
questions like how long do people live,
um,
how subject worthy to early death
from diseases like the plague.
Uh,
what age did they get married?
Who tells their marriage partners?
What was the quality of
their family relationships,
how many people could read,
and what did they read if they could read,
um,
how do people make their livings?
And how did the economy change?
What were the levels of crime and violence
and how well were they controlled,
and a host of other questions which are
not previously accessible because we
don't have adequate sources so one can
begin to get a sense of the rest of the
population.
And to give you just one
particular example round
about 1900 box of papers with
founding the sellers of
Worcester College Oxford,
and they turned out to be the papers of
the secretary of the Council of Oliver
Cromwell's army and included a verbatim
shorthand account of debates which had
taken place in 1647 at the end of the
civil war when the council of the army
debated the settlement of the
kingdom in the aftermath of the war.
One of the extraordinary things about
this verbatim account is that you hear the
voices of the common soldiers.
One of them who's representing a cavalry
regiment keeps interrupting the debate.
He keeps saying,
what is the soldier fought for all this
time uses the phrase again and again,
what does the soldier fought for?
And it's thrilling because you hear for
the first time the voice of the common
people erupting into the
councils of the nation.
Well,
that's symbolizes in a sense what the
available documents enabled people to do
from the 16th century onwards.
Secondly,
looking at early modern England
can engage the intellect.
The historical literature
is exceptionally rich.
It's very large,
created by generations of historians
from all over the English speaking world
and quite a few of the most significant
of them were well yell scholars.
This literature has produced many of the
classic works of historical writing in
the English language and it's also
proved to be restless and innovative and
rather argumentative.
All of the recent movements in historical
research and writing are represented
amongst its practitioners,
mainstream political and
constitutional history,
gender history,
the new social history,
the new cultural history
influenced by critical theory,
what people now describe as
the new political history,
which tries to reintegrate
social and political development.
All of this is represented and much more.
Um,
since the 1960s in particular,
it's been one of the most
vigorous of historical traditions.
There's plenty there to
engage the intellect,
whatever it is that you happen
to be most interested in.
And thirdly,
it helps to understand ourselves in time.
Of course,
all periods of history do that,
but the events of the early modern
period have a peculiar resonance,
the events and processes
of these centuries or have
more than merely historical
interest if you're concerned with the
institutions of representative government
and how they came into
being for the first time.
If you're concerned with the
notion of the rule of law,
if you're concerned with the structures
and dynamics of a capitalist market
economy,
if you're interested in concepts of
individual liberty and collective
responsibility or with the excesses of
religious fanaticism or with innumerable
social and cultural attitudes which
continue to echo in our own relationships
and in our own time,
if we only know how to recognize them.
I mean if you're concerned
that the language itself,
then early modern England has
got a great deal to say to you.
It's because of these issues are so alive
in the literature of the period that
the literature is so rich.
And it's for that reason also that it's
very much an international literature.
These issues concerned scholars
from all over the world.
And as a further dimension to that too,
which is that a great deal of what
happened in 16th and 17th century England
later impacted upon a much wider world.
The history of early modern England
is by extension very much a part,
not only of British history,
but also of American and Canadian
Australian and New Zealand history.
It's got things to say about
the history of India and Africa.
Some of the things that happened in this
period left their fingerprints all over
the world in all kinds of ways.
I mean,
they,
it certainly left its fingerprints
on new haven to come close to home.
Um,
if you look around the town,
I mean,
you look at the churches,
the episcopal,
Presbyterian,
congregational baptists,
Quakers,
all of his religious traditions have
their origins in 16th and 17th century
England.
Or if you look at the street
names running out of Broadway,
we have golf,
Wally and Dixwell streets.
Um,
all three of them named after three of
the man who signed the death warrant of
King Charles the first in 1649
and later hid out in new haven,
which was a radically puritan colony,
which gave them asylum after
the return of the king.
Uh,
our suburb of Hamden is
named after John Hamdan,
who in 1637 stood up against the policies
of King Charles the first and tried to
fight him in a landmark legal case.
And if you start turning to
other place names in Connecticut,
I mean just gets ridiculous.
Um,
I mean we have new London.
Okay.
As Old London,
uh,
we have no which or Norridge
as it's pronounced in England.
It's up there.
A new haven itself is down here.
Uh,
we have Litchfield that's over there now.
We have Durham,
she was up there.
Now we have Stanford was there,
but
uh,
we have Greenwich,
which is over here,
same place names.
They're just in a different configuration
and in a sense that that's symbolic of
the relationship between British and
early modern in a America early American
history,
same names,
different configuration,
slightly different meanings.
So in a sense,
a good deal of this is American history
by extension and of consequence to
everyone who's become
involved in America's story
over the last two and a half
centuries
to explore it is to explore
part of your own identity.
Right?
Well,
this course is intended to provide
an introduction to all of this.
Um,
it's up to date.
It's also intended to be very
inclusive in its range and contents.
We will run through from the late 15th
century to the early 18th century.
We look at the momentous
changes and innovations,
which took place in 1500 England
was very much a personal Monaco.
The king really ruled by 1700.
It's a constitutional monarchy in which
the center of political life was a
permanently sitting elected parliament
and it's become not simply the kingdom of
England,
but the United Kingdom of England,
Scotland,
Wales,
and Ireland
in 1500 England was part of Catholic
Christendom practicing a very lively and
vital form of late medieval Catholicism.
By 1700 the country was aggressively
Protestant with an established church of
England,
which could no longer contain all the
varieties of Protestant denominations,
which had emerged leading to the granting
finally of religious toleration in the
late 17th century by 1500 in 1500 it was
largely a localized economy of peasant
families and urban craftsman.
By 1700 it was a highly
commercialized market economy,
capitalistic,
instructure and engaged in
trade with a much larger world,
especially with the east and with the
Atlantic in 1500 it's a world of rural
communities and small towns
with only one significant city,
London by 1700 it was the most
rapidly urbanizing country in Europe.
London had become the biggest city
in Europe and the kind of prototype
metropolis in 1700 London was
regarded as a kind of shock city.
The way people thought about
New York in the mid 20th century
in 1500 most people were illiterate
by 1700 literacy was widespread.
There was a vigorous print culture
including the first English language
newspapers and so one could go on and
on pointing the contrast between the
beginning and the end of the period.
The story of these and other massive
transformations used to be told as a kind
of triumphalist story and unfolding of
British destiny what people refer to as
the Whig interpretation of history.
Very nationalistic take on
the history of this period.
It traced the growth from the
16th century of political liberty,
religious freedom,
economic opulence and world power
as a kind of steady upward ascent.
Sometimes it had to be hard fought against
the forces of tyranny or superstition
or backwardness,
but in a sense it was portrayed as being
almost preordained the kind of English
version of manifest destiny.
Well,
since the 1950s the perspective
has changed massively.
Britain's place in the world has changed.
People think about its
history differently.
New Forms of history have been pioneered,
other voices or now heard,
especially the voices of the losers in
these processes or the people who only
had a subordinate place in,
um,
these achievements.
As a result,
we've now got a less one sided and in
many ways a more mature historiography.
We've got over the old tendency to Strut
and swagger about Britain's historical
road.
The changes of the 16th and 17th centuries
now seem very far from preordained.
I'd to say the less one sided perspective
reveals the losses as well as the
gains,
the failures,
and the crimes as well
as the achievements.
The point is,
it's all part of the story and
it's all available to be studied.
Well,
let's look briefly at the syllabus.
It's roughly chronological.
There's a timeline running
through the whole thing.
Um,
but as it develops,
there are overlaps.
Um,
I planned it as a kind of building
up of layers of knowledge,
each one acting as a kind of
stepping stone to the next.
In the earliest lectures,
lectures two to six I'll concentrate on
trying to establish some of the contexts
of society,
economy and government as they
were in the early 16th century.
I'd be looking at the
household at local communities,
at people's social and economic roles
and relationships at the structures of
power and authority as they
were at the time of kings,
Henry the seventh and Henry the eighth
roughly between the 1480s and the 1540s
that's to establish the context
because as has been said,
the discipline of history is
essentially a discipline of context.
Facts acquire their meaning only
when one understands the context,
which helps us to grasp their meaning.
So we'll set up the context.
Then from lecture seven we move into
the tracing of change lecture seven and
eight we'll look at the impact of
the reformation and the opening up of
religious divisions between the 1530s
and the 1550s in lecture nine we'll pause
to look at some of the problems which
were produced by the massive population
growth which began in the 16th century
and the economic stirring which that
produced in Lexus 10 and 11 I
look at the England of Elizabeth,
the first focusing on the problems in
religion and in a government policy faced
by the queen,
the struggle for stability and the
immensely insecure environment which she
inherited.
And then in lectures 12 and 13 I'll
go on to look at some of the principal
features of social change under Elizabeth
and the early Stuart's looking at
roughly the 1580s through to the 1630s
a period of major transition in society
and economy,
uh,
lectures 14 to 17.
We'll look at various aspects of social
and cultural change in the same period.
The later lizard beaten
early Stewart period.
I look at the witch craze of that time.
I look at crime and disorder,
a popular protest and rebellion
and at literacy and education.
Then in lectures 18 to 19 we'll come to
the religious and political tensions of
the early 17th century,
uh,
which eventually exploded in 1642 into
the civil wars we're trying to look at in
lectures 20 and 21 and the establishment
after the execution of King Charles,
the first of the English republic,
which lasted until 1660.
Okay,
that's a 22.
We'll look at the restored monarchy after
1660 tracing it up to the revolution
of 1688.
Uh,
that's your 23.
We'll look at the rapid economic
development of the late 17th century,
which provided the resources
to back the matter,
our treat in lecture 24 which was the
creation of a new state structure and the
emergence of Britain as a
significant world power.
So that's the rough timeline.
Those are the issues
which will be covered.
Obviously the course has an
essentially narrative structure,
but it's also very much
an analytical narrative.
It's about trying to understand how all
of these changes intersected with each
other,
how they influenced each other over time.
And I suppose that's
what really interests me.
Trying to grasp the wholeness of
the process of historical change,
how it all fits together.
And that's the best reason for doing
an outline course of this kind did,
enables you to see these
developments in the round,
all the different aspects,
how they intersect.
Now the readings which is
suggested on the syllabus,
um,
will help you hopefully to do all of that.
They've been chosen quite carefully.
The three textbooks are available
from the Yale Bookstore.
The cost packet of additional selections
from various books and articles is
available from Dakar
print down on Whitney.
Um,
the address is given on the syllabus and
the phone number and all of these works
are also on reserve in
the library in Sterling,
the reading runs at about a
hundred to 150 pages a week.
Now,
some of the readings you'll
find are quite demanding,
but I make no apologies for that.
Um,
you can say it's a mark of respect for
the capabilities of the students that I'm
setting some pretty
challenging stuff at times.
But if you follow the
readings as we go through,
you should build up a coherent grasp
of the whole period in its different
aspects and be introduced to the work
of some of the best historians currently
writing about it.
In a sense.
It's a course in good lucid,
robust historical pros,
the readings and the lectures.
Together we'll provide the basis
for the section discussions,
um,
which will tend to develop an add to
the lecture themes rather than simply
repeating to them,
repeating them.
And um,
two of the sections will be,
um,
visits to the British art center to look
at some of the visible evidence there.
Um,
those visits have to be on a Friday
morning and they are optional.
They're not part of the
examinable nature of the course,
but they're there.
If you're interested in,
we'd like to go along okay.
Within the sense of the whole period,
which I hope you'll develop.
Um,
you'll,
you will be asked to do two
pieces of more detailed work,
a shorter paper of about five pages
and a longer one of about 10 pages.
The first due in week seven,
the second you in week 14.
This should give you an opportunity
to develop personal interests.
Um,
you can have a completely
free choice of topic.
You can write your papers about any
aspect of the period that you find
interesting and you want
to pursue more deeply.
Um,
I'll give out,
um,
in a couple of weeks' time,
a list of topics that might interest you.
Um,
but feel free to bring forward
suggestions if your own,
um,
that you'd like to investigate.
Um,
or things you might pick up from lectures
that you want to take further and so
forth.
I also see a longer bibliography
which will help to prepare,
uh,
for those papers.
Um,
and which will also include material
if you'd like to look at the history of
Scotland or Ireland or Wales.
Um,
then there'll be material there on,
on,
on their developments.
Also all you need to do about the papers,
um,
is to consult with me or with the
teaching fellows to get advice on the best
reading,
uh,
for researching the papers and,
um,
uh,
subject to that.
Um,
you have a free hand,
whether that's some of the classical
issues of the period or whether it's other
things that you simply have to have
happened to have an interest in.
Last year someone was interested in public
health and ended up doing work on the
plague in early public health measures.
For example,
um,
we had a person also who was
interested in pregnancy and childbirth.
Well,
you know,
you can do that.
There's a literature on it and so forth.
Whatever it happens to be,
the overall assessment will be,
um,
15% for participation and discussion.
20% for the short paper,
40% for the long paper,
and 25% for the final exam,
which will be an examine,
which you'll be required to write two
essays from quite a large choice of about
20 topics covering the whole range.
Okay.
Finally,
um,
let me introduce,
the teaching fellows.
Um,
uh,
we have Courtney Thomas,
and Lucy Kaufman and Justin Gary Vij.
Um,
all of us will be available to assist you.
in section discussions,
of course,
we shed the old seven sections with
a quite a wide spread of times,
which hopefully will cater
for everyone who's interested.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we will it be available
of course in office hours,
uh,
teaching fellows will explain their
office hours when sections begin in third
week.
Um,
I'll be available usually on Tuesdays
between five and seven and on Thursdays
between two and 4:00 PM,
uh,
in both cases,
right?
Other times by appointment.
And of course,
we're all available by
email when necessary,
uh,
throughout.
Uh,
the basic,
uh,
teaching philosophy for
this course is quite simple.
First of all,
history should be challenging,
but it can also be fun.
And secondly,
if students are going to do well,
they deserve attention.
So if you want it,
you can have it.
Okay.
So this is a terrific period to study.
It has a terrific literature to work on.
Yale has a long and distinguished
tradition in this field
and fabulous resources
for studying it.
In the libraries and the British arts
centre in the special collections.
My objective is simply to encourage you
to engage with this field and to use
these resources and to do well to
achieve your potential and to enjoy it.
I've been teaching and researching and
writing about this period for about 40
years.
Um,
Courtney and Lucy and Justin
have been added less long.
Um,
but they know their stuff.
We have three teaching fellows
who really know their stuff.
They have their own special interests,
but they're very familiar
with the whole picture.
We are in a position to guide you and
help you get the most out of this course
and doubts in engaging in discussion
with you and in discussing your paper
topics and so forth.
We will also learn from you
people new to the subject.
Always see things that one's missed no
matter how long one has been working on
it.
So we'll be happy to do all of that.
So if the course attracts you,
take it and use it and use us to
develop your knowledge and your skills.
That's what we're here for.
And if anyone wants to ask
any particular questions,
just come on up at the end.
Okay.